[Music]
welcome everyone to the next class today
it's the games you should know by heart
famous games basically and this game I
choose I knew this game because a play
by Hikaru Nakamura a long time ago about
ten years ago actually in Spain a casino
the Barcelona tournament this they still
have this tournament it's every year
round-robin tournament they have they
actually play in casino so it would be
kind of distracting you know to be like
you know to be able to you know play
chess and then go gamble or something
you know so anyway this is a game
between me Kyle crossing Cole at that
time 2670 player and Hikaru
it was twenty six fifty almost and
interesting crossing Cove is a much
older player and he had a really great
year like last year at this year and his
rating is like up there now like again
you know like he made like he's again
like over 26 50 I think so it's it's
nice to see some of the veterans to make
another push you know and get up there
so it's very nice so he's playing with a
white pieces and Hikaru is black here
so Knight f3 Knight f6 c4 e6 g3 so looks
like crossing Cove wants to go for the
you know this should be to cut alone
type of position and we hit b3 double
fianchetto so I had this position
recently and I choose the move b6 here
b6 Bishop e7 you know you equalize but
it's not so simple dispositions white
still has some pressure so a5
immediately immediately he is trying to
be aggressive here and try to play some
a four ideas
okay Knight c3 what else yeah what we do
here you don't want to allow the move a
four because that will weaken the
position so that's why he played Knight
c3 to prevent that
okay if you play the move d4 then they
go Knight d5 and it it gets it gets
messy you know
so c5 then they play III they break 90
is very strong here so you might regret
allowing that so you got c6 Hikaru
but then d4 now White has nice
development control of the center and
basically he's saying okay what you
gonna do now the pawn on e5 is stopped
and you're still behind in development
9b d7 Queen c2 now after Queen c2
another major plan here is to play E for
to try to break the center okay this is
another idea to play E for you play b6
and crossing off goes for it yeah he's a
pretty ambitious player so you know you
know so he went for it and I'm sure at
that time he was even hydrated playing
with a white pieces so he was thinking
about I'm gonna go for a win Bishop a6
pinning Knight d2 here played because
what to do I mean you can't play the
movie 5 but this doesn't do too much
because Knight goes back on the 8th and
then will reroute to c7 at some point
there is also c5 break into account so
like you would go rook to e1 maybe even
black and take a pawn I don't see any
any big problems at least immediately so
he didn't want that to happen so he
played a move 92 just trying to keep the
balance that way he also opens up his
bishop the bishop is now putting lots of
pressure so c5 breaking the center
another move that I would have
considered is rook c8 it seems natural
to bring the rook into the game it will
be very useful here putting some
pressure here on a C file but he got a
plate c5 also another aggressive it's
aggressive more so it takes
see txt for attacking the night night b5
activating the night and also putting
pressure on before so let's say if
you're wondering why not capture right
take take actually wait you're right
take first this is the problem and now
eight hanging bishop hanging and
everything heinous something like this
will be really bad for block because his
light scores are very weak night goes on
c4 yeah so this is very bad so see takes
d5 plate now Knight takes d4 and rook c8
so this is what he was aiming for and it
looks like black is well-developed
he's ready to take I mean white has to
show something concrete here otherwise
he doesn't have much rook e1 was played
by crossing cove another move that
seemed natural and appealing was to play
Bishop b2 but I guess there's nothing
really no advantage to here whatsoever
because you have to take back with the
pawn if you take with a night I think
you run to be 5 so rook e8
b5 trying to take advantage of the pin
here and open up the position would be
five okay very ambitious play very
ambitious played by nakamura Bishop b2
now he goes rook e8 the point of rook e8
is Knight f5 is coming so he wants to be
able to tuck in the bishop on FA this is
usually when the night comes to f5 it's
very dangerous we know the night on a5
is a danger so you don't want to lie to
be there but the the best way to defend
is to go Bishop f8 to keep everything
under control
okay so that's known to be the fact so
if 95 you go Bishop afraid now
classical decides to retreat because if
he plays 95 just Bishop f8 so that's why
he goes Queen d1 Hikaru takes he is a
pawn up threatening to play c3p takes
and now he played the move Queen b6
immediately attacking the bishop I guess
if he had captured then knight c6
attacking the Queen and this gets
complicated
so Queen b6 now the bishop is under
attack rook b1 and he takes the idea is
now again at some point he wants to play
c3 he's up upon he has a pretty
comfortable position but again it's it's
sharp because there's some discovery
ideas there the rookie zombie wants to
search there's some tricks 96 activating
the night and now he is getting ready to
take on f6
like if you move the bishop he just goes
Bishop takes f6
so he goes rook c6 crossing coffee's
happy he takes on f6 now the queen is
under attack and if you move the Queen
he takes only 7 ok now what to do here
in this position no let's think let's
think this is a very important moment
here the Queen takes b1 he will just
take back so
this is the moment where you want to
really spend some time and try to find
the right idea here huh okay very good
very nice so we at least you we're in
the right direction here that's the idea
queen f2 sacrificing the queen he has to
take otherwise you just take on f6
Europe material and now Bishop c5 very
important if you try to take with f6
here then he is just gonna go king to g1
and yeah so Bishop c5 now if you go to
f1 guess what this Bishop comes in from
this side of the board so it's like
threats all over the place here not not
to mention he can take on f6 with the
check so he goes King f3
now checking the King and now hit if he
takes by the way what you going to do
here because if you take there's a root
be one thread Bishop see a check
yeah but you don't want to start
defending so you continue checking him
and now if he comes up here rook takes
check and if he goes here bro page six
he might just even Bishop e7 sorry where
I have six
a lot of threats here but maybe it's we
were just better just to take what do
you think of just just take and let's
say he goes G for you have a check here
and rook h6 mate so
Bishop c5 Knight
Aoife so he really had to calculate this
Bishop c8 line as well but his opponent
played King g5 now yeah you have some
pieces but you need to bring more pieces
right I'll check first right check first
if he goes to a five then you go Bishop
c8 so it was here now f6 waiting all dem
oh that's a very strong move because
that move is setting up a mating thread
do you see the thread rook h6 is a
threat
now you're trading to simply made so he
goes rook takes to eliminate that threat
what do you do check
now your move Bishop c8 now your move
comes in yes and now you're threating
mate on h6 how can he stop that well
Queen h5 I think it just stops it for
very short time and that's a mate and he
resigned this is the last move Bishop c8
what a way to end the game here what
away you know I takes rook takes d5 I
mean the threat is through cage six by
the way if you place g4 now do you
remember the mating idea if you ever
plays g4 here what's the mating idea
bishop f2 check perfect he goes here h6
mate very nice okay so that's the game
Bishop c8 so what we gonna do is we're
gonna do an over review of this game and
plus some people join us little a so
they can see everything as well okay so
let's review this game and see now if
you remember this game it's only 28
moves that way you'll see so is a very
nice win for hick our own and not too
many people know about this game but
it's a really nice sequence alright not
too often you can sacrifice your queen
against the strong play lacrosse and
Cove and win a brilliancy like this so I
play the white moves and you need to
find the black moves okay okay go ahead
Knight f6 is six yeah g3
Bishop g2 correct and the first surprise
first little surprise came right here
right where he called didn't just play
b6 there should be seven or c5a five
ambitious yeah you could see that he was
already ambitious you know by playing
this one because he wants to play a four
and put some pressure Knight c3
but now you know if you play d4 again
I'd be five it's not so good
c6 right keep the center under control
mm-hmm Kiefer by the way now now if he
plays the move Bishop b2 what kind of
strong move you have here yeah you can
try to consider d4 here because he can
no longer play Knight b5
okay so d4 Knight cannot go anywhere has
to go here
c5 okay
what then would happen on III though no
it's playable it's not it's not it's not
like wait wait I think I'm missing no I
cannot play b5 here that the a8 is
singing okay I was thinking about b5 but
then the rook is hanging sir oh it's
some kind of bin only type of position
I mean it's playable position no I mean
we don't have to play d4 but it's just
an idea so but cussing cough stop that
and now what is Hikaru play here what
ninety seven correct
now which piece which piece you need to
still develop so you have the complete
complete development still needed then
nice
efore is breaking the center now white
is trying to I think we need a little
bit more development we need a little
efore it seems logical to do it
I mean maybe rook e1 or Bishop b2 maybe
yeah he could have done that well I
think both players were ambitious in
this game you know both of them were
trying to go at it and you know see who
will prevail early now so knit excellent
now Knight d2 opening up the bishop I
was thinking about rook c8 here I think
that's the move that maybe I would have
considered here but maybe this was some
really strong preparation by Hikaru B
and he just went for it you know but
what did he play I like Luke c8 here but
what's the other a move here c5
completely opening up the center very
sharp very sharp stuff here happening so
he takes
now the night is under attack so he goes
95
well wisher takes me five we discussed
this right because then he takes here
and things are starting to loosen things
are loose here so that's why we just
take eat XD he takes continue absolutely
rooks here because he's threatening what
is he threatening everyone 96 right 96
is threatened so you prevent that and
plus you bring the rook in to move away
from that diagonal the bishop is under
attacking yeah rook e8 absolutely b5
now
rook e8 first so if Knight f5 remember
he wants to be able to tuck in the
bishop on f8 night the fire comes in he
wants to be able to go bishop f8 queen
d1 take take first because Queen b6
he'll take your pawn he is he couldn't
take it because the Queen was so now
he's ready to take so takes Queen b6 now
the bishop is under attack rook b1 and
now it seems like you know I can tell
you from my experience it's hard to play
this position because you know White has
threats to this is this wasn't a one-way
gaming I mean it got there but it looks
like black just won but they will have
threats you know I'm sure he Karl had to
calculate a lot of this stuff too
because white is not shying away he's
got a lot of active pieces here to do
the stuff so takes my thing is maybe you
know in some point okay this is 96 maybe
this was the critical moment here maybe
you should have just played Bishop out
here first hitting the Queen get hit
temple and then do that that might have
helped him a little bit to get the rook
active 96 rook takes his six so if
Bishop takes his six you just take with
the Queen so that's not good so he took
and looks like now the queen is under
attack and a seven bishop is hanging you
have a rook hanging and if not this move
you had a big trouble here but that's
where the winner comes Queen takes f2
sacrificing the Queen
he takes absolutely otherwise he goes
back to g1 C if you take on f6 he just
goes back on she once so you gotta keep
that King in the game okay if he goes to
f1 don't take because he'll go Knight f3
sorry if you take he will go
shop f3 and when you go check he escapes
and he's happy
ok so how are you gonna keep him there
c3 check got it
man it's just over I was looking at that
I thought rookie - I think even see -
then it goes Bishop over I mean look at
6 Bishop g2 I think what about c2 I was
thinking maybe c2 Bishop e2 check
I'm thinking check check and a lot of
extra material usually this kind of
positions you just have too many moves
here like when you have so many pieces
attacking so he went here check and now
it still yeah it's not so it's not that
you go check check and you made it's not
so trivial here you still had to correct
so if he takes if you take his route be
a check so you want to go
Bishop c8 first okay now he goes here
yeah we might even have yeah but I like
this we might even have something else
but I think this take right we say that
this is better yeah I mean this looks
this looks very tough rook h6 is the
mating tread so Bishop f3
I think I saw made here yeah who can see
the mating to here yeah
just want to want to excellent Claudio
excellent or g5 if you if you want to be
really brutal you can play g5 yes
now take Queen is there yeah so that
didn't happen so he played check
now no he didn't do this so he played
here
now well here 93 I think very very
strong so he won here so let's let's
look at King f5 right somewhere
Bishop c8 well we still have to find a
mate you know it's I mean yeah yeah well
here I'm pretty sure there is a force
made here you know well maybe this last
check guys so so he played King age five
obviously he calculated that he's losing
here so let's just see how is it losing
King f5 okay
so let's let's make sure we know this
one this gets mated by this is mate so
he has to go
let's see trick
Seaforth sang again so so check oh we
might we might need to play like a quiet
move maybe 96 King D 5 where do you go
like a look this six maybe look this 6
and then f5 is a threat that might be
the way to it yeah or rugby 6 also roopd
4 is a threat so it's most like root D 6
very nice yeah it's like cuts everything
off okay King D 5
I mean we might be able to win some
material but yeah I think Rock the sixes
gödel get a job done Rock t6 with a five
trade so he went here guys so you went
to yeah but this is I thinking if I was
a much better try this is just this is
just lost down maybe he missed this move
you know it's a it's a nice smooth nice
little neat move you know what is the
movie rf6 threatening Rock h6 mate it's
just simply trying to measure so he goes
here check
so what's the idea
take
that's it all right yeah okay very good
yeah that was good good good win for a
good win for hikaru against cross nakum
now I have a position I want to show you
okay this is a game of Vladimir Kramnik
against a greased choke two very strong
Russian grandmasters okay playing so let
me let me set this up for you and see if
you can find this okay so this is a
positional it's a topic on a positional
advantage okay so like White has a
positional advantage because of that
Bishop only four right so the light
squares are weak so there's a lot of
danger here so you need to find a way
here to to improve your advantage here
so here I'm asking you to play like
Kramnik to win this game against Greece
shook so take your time a little bit
because it's not so easy to see because
you're down upon and there are some
opposite colors there's opposite colors
on the board as well so if you take the
Queens after borders could be some
chances so and the black King is weaker
so that's important to know you have the
blocking is weaker
g6 well here just take the rock that's
an interesting idea then
but stroke here let's say aha aha aha
did you hear that everybody Claudio can
you say it repeat that what are you
trying to do here
h4 by cloud you're very strong yes
threat is h5 and that looks pretty
deadly right because then you take on g6
the problem now for him is he cannot go
back that is a major problem because if
it goes here now show me the winner
Czech takes Queen to f7 ok
so h4 h h5 okay grief shook played this
one because he didn't see anything
better so he played h4 h5 and now queen
d1 fantastic move protecting the rook
now this is under attack as well and now
the threat is Queen takes h5 double
attack now and Cooke resigned okay let's
see why he resigned I mean you know
sometimes you have this top grandmasters
resigned because they just see three
moves later they're losing but to make
it clear for you and for other players
watching this so what's the winning plan
Rock d7 rook belongs on a seventh we
know that if he comes here then we just
take take and thank you very much let's
thank you very much right there so he
has to play Queen f6 and now what's the
simplest simplest move here
now your threating check and you pick up
on a eight and you have the past pon
rolling down the borders well again all
this happened because of the dominating
Bishop only four that's a very strong
piece as a comparison to this one this
one is just defending very very passive
that this is a very very powerful Bishop
right there you have only four everybody
got it
perfect that's a tough move cloud your
good job on finding this strong move by
Claudio yeah h4 yeah h4 yeah you always
said to when you see the position is
weakened like this
you play h4 with idea h5 - you want to
do this in order to win okay no it's
lost actually after this but h4 it's a
very tough move to find I can tell it
this is not a easy move it doesn't you
have to realize that you want to go
clean d1 here and say let me flick in
this h4 h5 right so when I go Queen d1
h5 is hanging so that's that's the
reason okay so that's why
okay next position fairly balanced look
in endgame right
but Kramnik is so good at just winning
this kind of balance looking positions
you know that are slightly better for
him he's so good at converting this so
this is the game kramnik versus another
very strong Russian grass master
grandmasters Tomashevsky white to play
and find the plan here it's not win I
mean you're not gonna win this game in
one or two moves here but you need to
find a plan here to be able to to get a
position he won this like it's amazing
he want this position in eight months
I mean it looks kind of eco right I mean
everything is balanced and it doesn't
look like anything major happening here
before followed by well before creates
lots of weaknesses you'll get
potentially forked or something so and
plus before the palm will become a
target too so he'll start attacking it
with a knight on d5 so let's see if you
can play like kramnik here
aha Knight c5 that is the correct start
he's activating his knight and attacking
on a6 first of all he just wants to win
the pond and also at some point if Ford
is gonna come into play for sure if he
goes rook c6 then what do you do I think
he should have played Rock c6 probably
96 takes and okay this is if this pants
weren't there it would have been better
for black you know more chances to hole
with the pass there it's not so easy so
White has good winning chances but
thomashefsky and you know like many
places you probably wouldn't want didn't
want to do this so he says okay I'm
gonna go here Knight to be forth
now what do you want to do here rook d6
absolutely now you know getting more
pressure in pieces are coming in now to
put some pressure on e6 and also you
have a pressure on a6 okay now it is
rook c8 otherwise you know route b6 and
attacking this so that's why he went
there the point is now he wants to go
rook c7 and then start giving you a lot
of checks so he wants to just force this
move to start giving you the checks and
you have to be careful if you take he
may trade everything and check for
example so that line doesn't work either
take only six with which piece if you
take with the rook 10 rook c5 if you
take what the night and this check King
goes to back rank take some be too
unpleasant yeah he doesn't want you
don't want a king on a background here
where the opponent has rooks you know so
that's why the next move is very
important by kramnik king d2 but then
look c7 Klaudia rook c7 and big problems
yeah and then he starts checking you
might you might begin need to be careful
there rook p6 I think he wants to escape
with something like this escape to a
draw you know
that's what he played good job F for
clearing the clearing the f3 square
clearing the f3 square for the King rook
a c7 Knight takes c6 why not Knight a 6
yeah well it's a good night first of all
but the problem is you get pinned it's
even worse so you take you keep the
night and you attack a looksie to check
look beat you but now now Kramnik played
the good looking move here but there was
something even stronger than that
ok so what are the f5 yes if I was even
better mood and what kramnik did kramnik
played 94 here but f5 is very good at
just fixing it there and now with a huge
threat of rock t7 bit surprised he
didn't play this move because it seems
pretty natural to cement the position of
the night only 6 so he actually played
another move 94 he is threatening rook
d7 check the rooks e7 rook be 693 so and
he end up getting this position White
has one upon and has good winning
chances in this end game so here you
have very good chances because first of
all the Knights are on the board and you
don't want to trade nights here you may
trade the rooks at some point because
four-on-three with the rooks after board
it's very very good chances because
Knight end games are very similar to the
pawn end games and often times if if you
can win the pawn end game that means you
have good chances in a night end game so
not always but that's just a general
rule I remember once I want actually
three on two just three and two and with
the Knights and I won't quite quite you
know quite easily but ok my opponent
didn't defend properly so for round
three it's just more pants on the board
it increases the chances
same goes for the rook Cena but the
rooks Luke endgame four-on-three it's
still it's still a draw you know but but
if you keep increasing the pawns then
it's more chances here so I think this
is important but yeah I think here f5 if
I might have just given even better
position rook d7 is just a very strong
move to deal with okay so here we saw
kramnik here basically we saw chronic
just you know from pretty equal looking
position with couple of moves improve
the position and then you know you get
the big advantage so it starts off with
95 Rock d6 and they yeah you don't want
this because that's just equal this one
I thought was very important see like
every these positions we are studying we
see a really difficult moves yes like in
this position the difficult move is f4
because you have to realize he's gonna
keep checking me I need to have a nice
shelter nice place for my King to go to
and then you discover that and you go
for the move f4 and putting the King on
f3 okay
I think that shouldn't be a big problem
right f5 rooks ec2 check I take my king
is actually even safe here it's no
checks the knight is not placed well
enough knowledge of 65 Roxy eight mates
yeah yeah taste you to that feels like
it should be winning somehow here yeah
they keep going to background so yeah so
I'm sure you can look it up this game
this is 2012 kramnik against
thomashefsky played in Moscow so one of
the super tournaments like a towel
memorial or something probably so you
can look that up if you want to get the
whole game here so I'm sure Cromley
pushed here another 20 moves here or
something most likely he won this
because it's it seems like okay now next
position again this is positional
advantages so this is white to play
kramnik white against lecco in a
Dortmund super tournament and kramnik
won this very nicely here what is
White's main advantage here excellent
thinking correct and black wants to
protect his rook with the King g7 and
then he's gonna be comfortable so that's
what you you know you will need to try
to do to you see wants to go King g7 and
then he can start jumping in with a
knight and stuff so that's why you have
to do something here yeah majority of
majority that is a positive that is a
positive as well yes
well I'm not sure about it because rook
takes yeah but this is not so easy I
mean here yeah but if I have to be I
have to take with a bishop then you have
96 but I'm I will not do that yeah
otherwise I lose now what to do now what
to do in this position
okay yes 93 excellent play perfect
excellent play that's what a lad Ameer
Kramnik did the point of this move is
Knight e5 just take this that is the
idea and also what is your second threat
what is the second threat of whites
besides ninety five night before you see
that huh perfect
so if King g7 you go night before if
King is seven you go 95 yes so he played
King it now night before doesn't make
sense behind I'll take you so you have
to go where you have to otherwise you on
pin the pin yeah now you want to take
this and win a piece if Knight moves you
will take on the eight and then three
years ago Bishop e6 you take on g6 so
you're up a pawn and still have a nice
position here if you play 97 then simply
take take and here just before King
comes to d4 with a victory so that's why
it doesn't 97 doesn't quite work we
played rook d7
and now you always have to remember that
in any game King belongs we're in a
center so you start bringing him in like
his stock he cannot do anything King f7
runs into 95 King d8 runs into 98 so he
goes here rook g7
now you take take your two pounds up
yeah your two pounds up now
I actually sorry sorry sorry he takes
here Bishop takes correct Luke takes and
now look up rook a six a troop takes
here yeah then you take and white white
wins this pretty easily rook b8 yeah so
if you attack he'll go here you don't
want to lose the beat to pawn you have
to be careful because if if you lose the
beat three and you have these two pounds
you know there's a theoretically drawn
it's difficult to do it but it's draw so
he will keep the b-pawn here he will get
the King in get the pawns rolling so
that should be a win here so once again
we see another position where you know
it's not that obvious the advantage it
looks like because you know if he goes
King yet it's just a one move matter of
one move here we see matter of one more
but Cromley gets the job down here and
he is won countless games like this in
his career so he is very good at
converting this kind of position so once
again the idea here is Knight d3 with
the threats of night before and 95 it's
always nice when you make a move and
creating two threats you know so it goes
here
95 threatening to win a bishop take King
comes in
he's a sook so back here he can't move
anything it's it's it's amazing you
cannot move the night Bishop c6 your
bishop cannot move your King cannot all
of you get forked here Knight of fate
here 95 so you have to go here and you
go here that's a win so yeah if you want
to improve your positional play Vladimir
Kramnik that's the guy you want to study
okay study his best games okay that's
that's very important you know of course
they're a lot more examples but you know
that's that's it for today and thanks
everybody for coming see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]